in today's cloud minute I'll show you a  few of the things you can do with the  cloud natural language API in Ruby cloud  natural language - syntax analysis  sentiment analysis and entity analysis  I've already set up authentication and  I've installed the Google Cloud language  gem to use the API first I need to  require google sauce cloud / language  now I need to create a language object  some content to analyze and a document  object to call the API I can call the  annotate method on the document  to see the positive or negative  sentiment score I call results stop  sentiment score the syntax analysis  provides an array of tokens which are  the words or punctuation in your content  to see the entities of the APA  identified I can do a similar block  this is just the surface of the natural  language API to learn more check out the  links in the video description